una salida entre sus seguidores para
celebrar su cuarto año en el poder el
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador estuvo este domingo en las
calles de la Ciudad de México la
manifestación organizada por el
presidente mismo reunió a miles de
personas en el centro de la ciudad
cuando él nos hasta en los momentos más
difíciles de la pandemia hemos
garantizado que a la gente no le falte
lo básico no ha habido hambre ni por eso
se ha mantenido la paz y ha permanecido
encendida la llama de la esperanza según
varias encuestas el presidente tiene una
tasa de popularidad alta con un 60% de
aprobación sabemos que no ha sido muy
fácil faltan muchos por hacer pero
estamos muy contentos de que el
presidente ha cumplido con la mayoría de
sus compromisos la marcha hace yo solo
unos días después de otra movilización
en la cual participaron miles de
opositores para protestar contra la
polémica propuesta de reforma electoral
en abril el presidente presentó un
proyecto de reforma del Instituto
Nacional electoral el órgano autónomo
que organiza las elecciones en México la
reforma que requiere el apoyo de al
menos dos tercios del parlamento podría
eliminar varias instituciones
importantes y concentrar la Organización
de las elecciones en manos del partido
gobernante la oposición denuncia un
riesgo para la democracia y algunos
Incluso acusan el presidente de querer
mantenerse en el poder Aunque López
Obrador prometió que no se presentará a
su reelección México celebrará
elecciones generales en 2024 según la
Constitución el presidente puede ejercer
un solo manda